en este vídeo vamos a hablar de la regla
de las potencias que simplifica mucho
nuestra vida cuando estamos haciendo
derivadas y en especial derivadas de
polinomios por supuesto que recuerda la
definición de derivada el límite cuando
delta x tiende a cero de fx + delta x
menos f x sobre delta equis y se refiere
básicamente al cálculo de la pendiente
en un punto y aquí es donde la regla de
las potencias nos facilita la vida y no
tenemos que hacer estos límites
complicados y en este vídeo te voy a
mostrar cómo funciona y en otro vídeo
voy a demostrar por qué es así y haremos
algunos ejemplos lo que nos dice la
regla de las potencias es que si tengo
una función digamos fx y fx es una
potencia de x como x a la n donde n es
distinto de 0 n puede ser cualquier cosa
sea negativo positivo un número decimal
no tiene que ser un entero
entonces la derivada de esto efe prima
de x va a ser igual a n veces x osea
bajas el exponente va a ser n x y luego
se decremento el exponente n 1 n veces x
a la potencia n menos 1 ahora hagamos
algunos ejemplos para verificar que esto
tiene sentido así que qué tal si nos
preguntamos si fx es igual a x al
cuadrado entonces de acuerdo a la regla
de las potencias f prima de x será pues
en este caso nuestra n vale 2 entonces
será bajar el exponente entonces será 2x
a la 2 menos uno que esto es igual a 2x
a la 1 que se simplifica como 2x
ahora vamos a pensar qué tal si tenemos
gdx que sea igual a x al cubo
bueno pues en este caso nuestra n estrés
como se ve en este patrón que tenemos
aquí y que prima de x será 3 veces x a
la 3 menos uno que es igual a tres veces
x al cuadrado y ya terminamos en el
próximo vídeo vamos a ver el porqué de
esta situación
mientras tanto hagamos otro ejemplo y en
este vamos a ver que la potencia no
tiene por qué ser enteros positivos
digamos que tenemos hdx que esta vez va
a ser igual a equis a la menos 100 que
nos dice la regla de las potencias pues
nos dice que h prima de x será igual a
menos 100 veces x a la menos 100 menos
uno que es igual a menos 100 veces x a
la menos 101 hagamos otro y esta vez
será zeta de x es igual a x
2.571 y queremos saber qué es z prima de
x y otra vez la regla de las potencias
nos simplifica la vida y esto es igual a
2.500 71 x a la 2.500 71 -1
y esto va a ser igual y a ver voy a
acomodar mi pantalla esto va a ser igual
a 2.500 71 x ala 1.571 otra vez la regla
de las potencias nos simplifica la vida
espero te haya gustado el vídeo en
próximos vídeos vamos a ver más de
derivación y en algunos casos
particulares vamos a demostrar esta
regla